samedi à 15h15 sur Public Sénat
suppression et les vocabulaires ont
leur importance le principe de cette
taxe reste un bon principe il faut
savoir d'ailleurs que ça vient du
Grenelle en 2008 sous l'ancienne
majorité voter à l'époque à l'unanimité
puis dans la loi de finances pour 2008
qui constituent la base juridique de
cette de cet écotaxe après la droite au
pouvoir a mis cette ecotaxe en oeuvre
dans des conditions c'est vrai qui sont
pas qui n'étaient pas satisfaisante
d'abord il y a eu le choix de la mettre
en oeuvre dans des conditions qui ne
sont pas satisfaisantes après le coup de
bambou fiscal
c'est la théorie de la droite ensuite on
a mis en ami en œuvre ils ont mis un
œuvre cette taxe à confiant un opérateur
privé ce qui coûte extrêmement cher
l'une d'ailleurs des problèmes
aujourd'hui c'est que si on arrête ça
coûte 800 millions que devrait payer
comme indemnité à cette opérateur privé
choisi par Madame
alors qu'elle était ministre de
l'Environnement pour faire cette
opérations
nous n'allons pas verser le débit les
quotas non les quotas n'est pas supprimé
elle est suspendue et nous allons
engager des négociations sur les
conditions de sa mise en œuvre sur le
principe attendez restons sur sur le
principe
qu'un consortium privé c'est assez
inédit dans notre pays soit chargé de
collecter cet impôts donc le ministre
Stéphane de folle avait dit que si on
arrête ça coûte 800 millions bon là
c'est reporté néanmoins la société peut
peut-être se retourner contre vous non
la société peut pas se retourner contre
nous il n'y a que si on passait à la
suppression qu'il y aurait son droit à
un amitié pour l'instant la société elle
est dans le cadre de l'application du
contrat dans lequel elle a déjà elle a
déjà un revenu annuel pour payer les
investissements vous lui dites de
patienter mais nous lui disons de
patienter naturellement vous dites que
ce n'est pas une suppression ça n'est
qu'une suspension vous allez grossir les
rangs des manifestants de
en Bretagne pourquoi vous voulez
pour vous avoir la capacité de dire que
ce qu'a dit le Premier ministre ce matin
que c'était suspendu ça voulait dire que
c'était supprimé il n'a jamais dit ça
ils veulent une suppression en Bretagne
particulièrement il se réunissent à
nouveau samedi certains voulaient une
suppression et c'est la plupart certains
nombre d'entre eux j'ai vu les réactions
sont d'accord sur la suspension pourquoi
la suspension c'est pas la suspension
pour dire on verra on la mettra en place
telle qu'elle est plus tard c'est
surtout pas ça c'est de dire puisque les
conditions de mise en œuvre de quelque
chose que nous avions déjà modifié je
veux dire un mot là-dessus en faveur de
la Bretagne en faveur de la Bretagne
quand on arrive il y a un abattement qui
existe déjà qui est de 25% qui a été
prévu pour la Bretagne puisse plus deux
autres régions un peu périphériques nous
l'avons porté nous avons engagé la
négociation nous l'avons porté à 50%
notamment pour la Bretagne mais il est
vrai aujourd'hui que pourquoi est-ce que
ça explose en Bretagne pour une une
raison très particulière c'est que c'est
la conjonction entre la une oeuvre de
cette taxe sur les poids lourds et la
crise sur la Bretagne simplement dans
les faits aujourd'hui il y a un lien
entre les deux mais il y a pas un lien
de cause à effet c'est pas les contacts
qui est à l'origine des difficultés de
la Bretagne et notamment de la
groennustrie et tout simplement elle
n'existait pas jusqu'à présent
aujourd'hui toutes les oppositions mais
vous avez été très clair effectivement à
l'indivaliste les quotas n'est pas
supprimé alors quand reviendrait-elle le
gouvernement a dit qu'il prendrait le
temps de la négociation pour parvenir à
un accord donc on n'a pas voulu on n'a
pas voulu donner le délai ça sera
forcément quelque chose qui nécessitera
plusieurs mois mais je peux pas vous
dire si ça sera de moi ou neuf mois ou
10 mois je n'en sais strictement rien
parce que il faut qu'il y ait le temps
de la négociation sur quoi va porter la
négociation vous savez que il y a
d'abord des des discussions des
précisions à avoir notamment s'agissant
ce qu'on appelle le cabotage c'est à
dire les gens qui pour leur travail font
45 ans 70 km tous les jours c'est-à-dire
finalement élargir des exonérations plus
un certain nombre d'activités
professionnelles et qui sont aujourd'hui
en crise qui ne l'était peut-être pas au
moment où les cotaxes a été a été décidé
et dont on va traiter secteur par
secteur des étages à l'usine à gaz là
écoutez le principe même de l'écotaxe
tel qu'il a été proposé par d'autres
donc je peux le dire à l'aise on l'avait
voté nous-même c'est un principe qui est
un principe cohérent c'est-à-dire qu'il
consiste à dire
l'usure de la route par le transport
routier fait que nous allons faire payer
y compris les camions étrangers et qui
passent sur les routes françaises de
manière à avoir des revenus qui sont des
revenus qui vont abonder ce qu'on
appelle la fuite c'est-à-dire l'Agence
de financement des infrastructures
autrement dit l'État et qui permettent y
compris en Bretagne d'avoir le
financement de projet important routiers
dans la Bretagne dans la Bretagne à
Bretagne voilà pourquoi il faut pas le
remettre en cause dans son principe donc
l'UMP Christian Jacob a tout faux quand
il demande la démission de Stéphane de
folle le ministre de l'AG qui disait que
on ne pouvait pas renoncer à l'écotaxe
donc effectivement on ne renonce pas à
l'écotaxe vous l'avez dit pas à l'écotax
Christian Jacob c'est une nouvelle
preuve de ce caractère très nuancé de
ses propos alors donc parlons avec vous
de suspension une suspension minable
selon José Beauvais qui semble dire tout
ce que pense les écologistes on se
souvient d'ailleurs que Jean Vincent
placé la veille de la décision du
Premier ministre avait dit que si le
gouvernement cède il ne faudra pas
s'étonner qu'il n'est plus aucune
autorité vous pouvez collectionner les
déclarations de ce type ce qui compte
c'est la réaction aujourd'hui la
réaction des écologistes et notamment du
sénateur mais il peut y avoir ici ou là
un élu c'est bien que c'est vous
trouverez toujours quelqu'un moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la position des
écologistes qui sont des partenaires
dans la majorité la réaction aujourd'hui
c'est de dire qu'il reste favorable à
cette taxe poids lourd mais qu'il
comprenne que dans ces circonstances
aujourd'hui la décision de suspension
qui a été prise est une bonne décision
c'est ce qu'ils ont dit et notamment ce
qu'a dit un sénateur écologiste à la
Réunion en Matignon et voilà il y a eu
un déjeuner de la majorité à midi et ils
ont repris collectivement cette position
c'est la seule qui nous a donné cette
petite musique toujours en arrière fond
on n'avait pas envie comme 56 % des
Français de virer les ministres écolos
du gouvernement vous à l'indice et
pourquoi vous voulez vous enfin c'est
ils font partie du gouvernement c'est un
pacte majoritaire ils ont soutenu
l'élection du Président de la République
et personne à l'intention de décider de
les virer ils sont partis intégrale et
importantes il y a des ministres
écologistes au gouvernement ils y sont
tout autre chose mais on reste dans la
dans la révolte fiscale puisque c'est
l'expression utilisée à quoi va servir
la réunion de l'Elysée jeudi avec les 8
représentants du football professionnel
parce que alors là il est pas question
de reculer j'ai envie de dire une
nouvelle fois si vous avez me reprendre
mais il est pas il est pas question de
il est pas question de reculer mais la
politique c'est aussi de la pédagogie il
ne sont pas d'accord on l'a bien compris
avec la décision qui a
semble-t-il le projet de grève et
quelque chose d'un peu indécent dans la
situation dans la situation
d'aujourd'hui
par contre naturellement le président de
la République quand
les partenaires des sociaux
professionnels même si un désaccord
demande à leur rencontre il affiche sa
position qui est pas circuler il n'y a
rien à voir qui est de toute façon je
veux expliquer je veux vous rencontrer
de manière à ce que même s'il y a un
désaccord le dialogue soit toujours
maintenu d'accord mais la position
affirmée clairement d'accord alors à
propos de François Hollande je vous
parlais du sondage qui montre son record
d'impopularité le monde se demande en sa
dernière manchette Hollande peut-il
encore agir que répondez-vous tous les
jours et il va continuer il va continuer
à agir je vois bien
dans les commentaires aujourd'hui il y a
une sorte de de commentaire ceux qui
consiste à dire ce président au fond
manquer de courage
très honnêtement est-ce qu'il y a eu
dans l'histoire de la République un
président qui a décidé pour l'intérêt de
la France de mener une politique dont il
savait par avant qu'elle était aussi
difficile quand vous rentrez dans un
quinquennat en disant aux Français
la situation est-elle que je vais vous
demander de faire des efforts
c'est-à-dire de payer des impôts
supplémentaires que je vais être obligé
d'en réduire la dépense publique et pas
souvent facile je veux dire c'est le
courage c'est pas des mots c'est des
actes et un président de la République
qui se dit que l'intérêt supérieur de la
France c'est de mener cette politique je
suis assez surpris qu'on puisse lui
contester le courage vous savez le
courage en politique il se mesure
justement dans la possibilité et dans la
détermination de prendre des décisions
qui sont les décisions que la situation
existe alors il y a la notion de courage
vous venez d'en parler il y a l'autorité
je l'évoquais à travers des
il y a aussi
la critique qui vise le chef de l'État
en lui dit on lui reproche de conduire
la France un peu comme il menait le
Parti socialiste toujours en ménageant
la chèvre chaud l'esprit de Saintes ou
le souci de la synthèse
j'entends ce débat et ça nous ramène
aussi à au débat au fond sur le sur le
courage
est-ce que le courage du dialogue et de
l'apaisement n'est pas aussi honorable
et méritoire que le pseudo courage de la
décision abrupte circulait il y a rien à
voir c'est moins de chef et j'ai décidé
et on sait très bien et ça a été sa
personnalité ça a été sa proposition
dans la France d'aujourd'hui avec tous
les antagonistes qui existent on le sait
bien c'est une situation sociale qui est
difficile on voudrait bien admettre
comme un Népalais seul responsable que
ce président que le président François
Hollande décide d'avoir comme marque de
comme ligne de gouvernance effectivement
de rechercher d'une manière systématique
le dialogue pour ne pas ajouter de la
fracture sociale ou de la fracture le
dialogue et la synthèse entre les
différentes tendances de sa majorité
présidentielle c'est pas simplement vous
savez entre les Français c'est au sein
même de son camp donc je vois pas
comment vous pouvez poser cette
affirmation il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de
discussion de ce point de vue là c'est
plus
lignes on va y revenir si on pense au
ministre qui défendent certaines
positions humanistes entre guillemets et
le ministre de l'intérieur on peut
apprendre la synthèse a été faite et
elle est juste en synthèse là encore non
la synthèse a été faite mais le Mons le
mont saint-espress de tout son poids il
y a une hyper dent ni gagnant si vous
faites allusion à la réforme de la
politique pénale qui sera débattue au
mois d'avril au Parlement néanmoins
est-ce que vous niez le fait qu'il
faudrait un électrochoc aujourd'hui pour
le pouvoir exécutif à l'invitalisé
lequel
je pense que l'électrochoc qui viendra
dans la société lorsque les premiers
résultats viendront on est dans la
situation aujourd'hui c'est vrai on a
demandé aux gens des efforts on a une
ligne politique surtout une ligne
économique qui est claire qui n'était
pas facile qui était courageuse et on
est dans la période où les premiers
résultats se font entendre ils vont
venir on le sait bien mais quand vous
passez de 30 000 chômeurs de plus par
mois au mois de janvier à 5000
aujourd'hui pour les gens ils ont raison
c'est toujours 5000 de trop sauf que
nous on sait très bien que quand on est
à 5000 c'est plus facile évidemment de
passer ensuite à zéro et à l'inversion
ce qui est de notre objectif donc on a
toujours dit que c'était ça la ligne et
je pense que lorsque les Français à la
fin de l'année verront les premiers
résultats sur ce qu'est l'objectif
majeur du gouvernement mais qui est
aussi leur préoccupation majeure à eux
c'est-à-dire la question de l'emploi
alors ça sera ça le choc salutaire pour
le gouvernement alors on a quand même
entendu récemment quelques élus
socialistes critiquer l'action du
gouvernement il y a même Bertrand
delanoué qui a dit qu'il ne comprenait
pas tout dans la politique qui est
suivie on a vu également quelques élus
claquer la porte du PS comme le sénateur
Philippe Esnol qui a changé de groupe du
coup il a trouvé refuge chez les
radicaux de gauche avant d'accueillir
Jean-Louis Prévot de l'Agence France
Presse paroles de quelques socialistes
en rupture avec Mounir souci
après 20 ans au PS David deroué a dit
stop le maire de Fleury-Mérogis a rendu
sa carte car à ses yeux un an et demi
après l'élection de François Hollande
sur le plan des réformes le compte n'y
est pas c'est surtout l'idée que et bien
aucun des engagements électoral fort n'a
été tenu en tout cas ceux qui
structurellement peuvent
fondamentalement changer notre pays ne
sont pas mis en oeuvre il n'est pas le
seul à avoir claqué la porte la semaine
dernière excédé par l'affaire léonarda
le sénateur mère Philippe Esnol a quitté
avec fracas le groupe socialiste pour
rejoindre les radicaux de gauche un
comportement critiqué par Marie-Noël
linman qui regrette ses départs selon
elle pour infléchir la ligne du parti le
combat de se mener grâce au débat
interne quand les choses vont mal et ben
les réflexes individuels prennent le pas
sur l'intérêt général donc je le
regrette et mais je pense qu'il faut
regarder le symptôme à son origine
c'est-à-dire dans une grande
décalage entre ce que fait le
gouvernement et l'espérance de nos
concitoyens régulièrement du peuple de
gauche aujourd'hui sans étiquette David
Derouen ne bénéficiera pas des moyens du
Parti socialiste pour mener sa prochaine
campagne municipale ce qui a ses yeux
n'est pas forcément un inconvénient vu
l'impopularité actuelle de la majorité
et beaucoup d'élus locaux sont comme moi
très en colère
d'ailleurs très nombreux sont ceux qui
disent surtout nous ne mettrons pas le
point la rose lors de l'élection
municipales cette défiance n’inquiète
pas une Solférino le parti considère ses
départs comme un épiphénomène et estime
que deux cas isolés n'auront aucun effet
boule de neige
voilà Alain virus Jean-Louis Prévot de
l'Agence France Presse notre partenaire
pour pouvoir par toi qui nous a rejoint
bonsoir Jean-Louis bonsoir bonsoir
Monsieur Thomas
avec le Parlement vous êtes bien placé
pour écouter les parlementaires pour
pour entendre un peu toutes les
remontées qui peuvent vous faire le
lundi lorsqu'ils reviennent de leur
circonscription de leur département
alors ben justement la gronde qui touche
actuellement la France est-ce que vous
l'avez entendu
la crise sur la Bretagne les contacts
l'incohérence un peu fiscale et toutes
les pilules fiscales est-ce que est-ce
que vous l'avez entendu est-ce que vous
êtes honnête fait le relais auprès du
gouvernement naturellement naturellement
dire les parlementaires quand ils
reviennent de leur circonscription se
font les coûts de ce qui ne va pas et
c'est extrêmement important pour le
gouvernement les réunions des groupes de
la majorité ou leur expression que ce
soit l'Assemblée nationale ou au Sénat
sont évidemment très importants qui a
régulièrement dans la semaine y compris
des réunions avec les présidents de
groupe les présidents des des assemblées
pour justement
enregistrer ces positions on peut pas
dire le contraire alors justement là
actuellement on a le texte sur la
réforme des retraites qui est au Sénat
bon le Sénat s'apprête à voter contre là
il ne sait pas une surprise le PS n'y
est pas la majorité en revanche à
l'Assemblée là il lui il a manqué 19
voix socialistes
au gouvernement qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire est-ce qu'on a frôlé une espèce de
blocage au sein même du PS dans cette
circonstance ou est-ce que les députés
n'ont pas été entendus à cette occasion
non mais écoutez la règle en politique
c'est que et en démocratie c'est que
c'est la majorité moi je veux bien
qu'on passe son temps à parler des 17
qui pensent que on peut voter contre le
gouvernement alors qu'on a été élu avec
la même étiquette je préfère vous parler
des 280 qui soutiennent la politique du
gouvernement bon c'est 17 c'est
regrettable c'est pas cohérent on a
droit de pas être d'accord mais on le
dit avant mais dans tous les cas sur un
vote aussi important le vote du budget
le vote du droit de financement de la
sécurité sociale et sur un texte aussi
emblématique que la réforme des
retraites je pense qu'il aurait dû
effectivement ne manquer aucune voix des
parlementaires de la majorité et que
c'est tout à fait regrettable ceci dit
ça n'empêche en rien le gouvernement
d'agir ni dans la quasi-totalité des
parlementaires de suivre l'action du
gouvernement
du PS il sera pris candidat socialiste à
Fleury-Mérogis mais regardez même à
Paris Anne Hidalgo fait campagne pour
les municipales pour la succession de
Bertrand Delanoë et elle l'a dit elle
prend grand soin de se tenir à distance
de l'action du Gouvernement sur le thème
ECE moi c'est moi qu'est-ce que vous
réagissez mais écoutez
cœur mère ou quand une candidat à la
mairie disent je ne veux pas rentrer
dans un débat qui est un débat
politicien sur pour ou contre l'action
du gouvernement parce que elle se dit ça
va me plomber ça va me plonger ma
candidate
c'est ce qu'on a compris oui mais c'est
ce que vous avez compris c'est bien ce
que je viens de dire mais c'est pas
exactement c'est pas forcément la vérité
commère tous les maires mais pas qu'à
cette élection là que c'est quoi une
élection locale tout le monde sait et
c'est une bonne chose que une majorité
60 % des électeurs quel que soit leur
tendance politique disent que ils vont
se prononcer en fonction de l'action
locale c'est spécifique aux élections
municipales il faudrait quand même être
irresponsable ou être un candidat assez
étonnant de dire ah bah attendez-moi je
vais pas vous parler de la vie puisque
vous prenez l'exemple des parisiens ou
de ce que je vais faire mais je vais
vous dire pourquoi c'est génial ce que
fait le gouvernement ou pourquoi je suis
pas d'accord je veux dire c'est une
réalité et tous les candidats évidemment
essayent et ils ont raison parce que ça
correspond à l'état d'esprit des
électeurs particuliers parce que
regardez là il y a une alliance entre
les socialistes et puis les communistes
que vous n'arrivez pas à obtenir sur le
plan national sachant que marinel linman
qu'on a vu il y a un instant
avec l'entrée des communistes au
gouvernement c'est une bonne chose qui
est une alliance Paris avec les comics
c'est pas une alliance d'opportunité
c'est une alliance entre ceux qui ont
dirigé la capitale pendant tant d'années
ensemble qui ont tenu leurs engagements
vis-à-vis des électeurs et qui ont
recigné ce contrat de confiance c'est
une façon noble de faire de la politique
revenir au travail parlementaire vous
avez quand même dans les dossiers un
certain nombre de grands textes de
grandes réformes comme la réforme pénale
la loi sur la famille que vous avez
repoussé après les municipales pourquoi
vous avez repoussé après les municipales
la loi sur la famille n'est pas passé en
conseil des ministres à leur où on parle
donc c'est quand même difficile et puis
j'ai
parfois je suis obligé de faire le bad
boy vis-à-vis des des autres membres du
gouvernement mais quand vous regardez ce
qui va se passer le Parlement arrête de
siéger le 28 février il y a des textes
qui sont passés il y a plusieurs mois en
conseil des ministres et pas des petits
textes la loi d'orientation agricole je
pense que le débat va être long dans les
deux assemblées latex sur le commerce et
porté par Sylvie happinel qui est un
texte aussi extrêmement important il
faut il y a le texte sur la déontologie
des fonctionnaires puisqu'on a fait pour
les élus on a donc on a des textes qui
sont passés il y a très longtemps plus
un certain nombre de textes donc je ne
suis pas complètement sûr qu'il sera en
finis au 31 décembre c'est pas parce que
vous ne craignez pas que ce soit des
textes qui portent un peu à polémique et
vous préférez éviter cette bonne
observation serait juste si ces textes
n'étaient pas passé en conseil des
ministres comment vous pouvez m'opposer
cet argument sur un texte puisqu'on fait
référence à la loi pénale par exemple
qui est passé en conseil des ministres
il y a plusieurs semaines maintenant ce
texte il est connu si quelqu'un veut
utiliser ce texte dans la campagne des
élections municipales nous sommes
complètement transparents le texte c'est
à dire le la position du gouvernement
elle est pas cachée c'est exactement
l'inverse nous avons passé le texte en
conseil des ministres votre argument
aurait quelques forces si on avait dit
on va pas dire ce qu'on veut faire et
puis on le dira après les élections
municipales on a dit depuis plusieurs
semaines ce qu'on allait faire voilà bon
pendant ce temps là on peut observer
Marine Le Pen qui engrange qui sur les
quotaxe par exemple elle reçoit elle
renvoie le PS et l'UMP deux ados est-ce
que ça va continuer pendant longtemps
est-ce qu'on va réussir est-ce que vous
allez réussir à l'arrêter
est-ce qu'on va réussir à ce que la
France va réussir à l'arrêter
au fond c'est vrai que ça la montée au
moins dans les sondages du Front
national aujourd'hui c'est une source
d'inquiétude et en même temps il faut
qu'on parle aux gens au fond on sait
très bien c'est pas nouveau que
l'extrême droite servent toujours sur la
crise que sur la crise économique et la
crise sociale mais il y a aussi des
éléments qui sont beaucoup plus
inquiétants si ce qui génère aujourd'hui
la montée éventuelle du Front national
c'est la montée
du rejet de l'autre c'est une une
fracture de la France le rejet de
l'autre qui a changé d'ailleurs au cours
des siècles avant c'était les Juifs
maintenant ça semble être plutôt les les
Arabes c'est c'est la République qui est
en cause et en même temps je me dis que
si des gens prennent le temps de
réfléchir qu'est-ce qu'elle propose au
fond une petite France une France qui a
peur de tout avec un projet économique
qui correspond à cette idée là c'est à
dire que on va s'enfermer dans nos
frontières et ce qui a un seul électeur
qui pense aujourd'hui que la France ce
qui est mieux si on fermait si la France
fermait ses frontières et alors les
centaines de milliers de salariés qui
travaillent chez Airbus pour vendre des
avions on va faire quoi on aura tous nos
avions pour nous ça n'a aucun sens
sortir de l'Euro avec la dette qui
exploserait immédiatement ça n'a aucun
sens personne ne peut croire à ça et je
pense je me dis que finalement ce que ce
qu'on a de mieux à dire c'est aux gens
qui sont tentés par ce vote là c'est de
leur dire est-ce que vous voulez de
cette France là pour vos enfants et je
pense que non je pense que sur le moment
ils sont comme ça peut-être séduit par
le fait qu'on a tout essayé que bon ça
va mal mais en même temps cette France
cette petite France là c'est pas la
France quand ils veulent pour leurs
enfants et je crois que ça c'est un
combat frontal c'est le combat pour la
République vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure que Christiane Taubira il a la
recherche d'un texte équilibré sur la
justice
il y a quelques semaines à votre place
il y avait l'UMP Gérard Longuet qui
estime lui que le carburant du Front
national c'est Christiane Taubira et il
nous l'a déclaré il nous dit c'est
Christiane Taubira qui fait le Front
national que répondez-vous à cela
je réponds que quand on s'interroge nous
aujourd'hui sur la porosité entre l'UMP
et le Front national monsieur Longuet
ses propos sont un très bon exemple je
vais ajouter quelque chose qui rejoint
un peu votre question et qui m'étonne au
fond il s'est passé des choses ces
dernières 72 heures les événements que
vous avez commandé les uns et les autres
pourquoi est-ce que dans l'actualité un
des événements les plus graves n'a pas
été à la Une moi ça me révulse que des
enfants accueillent Christiane Taubira
avec des bananes en faisant le cri de la
guenon il y a des gens en France qui
dressent des enfants à faire ça et ce
qui est très étonnant c'est que ça n'est
pas fait la une de l'actualité est-ce
que c'est pas aussi grave que les autres
débats qu'on a eu ce week-end et voyez
ce qui m'inquiète beaucoup c'est que
justement cet événement là était d'une
certaine façon pas totalement mais
banaliser alors que c'est une gravité
extrême effectivement mais là vous vous
parlez d'une instrumentalisation de cet
enfant une manipulation de l'enfant je
ne crois pas qu'il y ait des enfants qui
spontanément prennent des bananes pour
aller faire le cri de la guenon quand
ils voient une ministre quand Christian
Thomas vous contentez pas évidemment des
négations de la manif pour tous qui a
condamné ce fait lamentable en disant
nous n'y sommes pour rien c'est en
dehors de notre cause je ne sais pas qui
est responsable mais dans tous les cas
il y a des gens qui sont responsables de
ça et je crois que mettre cet événement
avec sa gravité dans le débat public
aujourd'hui ça me paraît essentiel pour
les municipales est-ce que ce ne sont
pas non plus des élections à risque pour
la gauche par exemple la Bretagne
actuellement qui est un peu où il y a
une jacquerie pourtant énormément de
municipalités sur bien ancré à gauche et
ça risque pas d'y avoir un basculement
je pense que le mieux qu'on a à faire
quand on affronte une élection c'est de
l'affronter sans aucune certitude et
plus on affronter les élections avec la
crainte plus on est déterminé justement
lever ces craintes donc je partage votre
analyse et tombe sous le coup du sens et
en même temps je crois que ça doit
renforcer justement et la détermination
des socialistes de la majorité des
majorités municipales dans leur ensemble
devenait ce combat face aux Français ce
qu'il faut pas quand même un électrochoc
pour
la question vient de mettre posée je
pense que
par exemple un remaniement on a évoqué
l'entrée de l'entreprise
ça passionne et c'est bien normal les
commentateurs la seule chose que sûr
c'est que le remaniement aura lieu un
jour voilà vous savez bien que le reste
personne n'en sait rien que les
conditions et c'est bien comme ça ces
présidents de la République estime s'il
doit le faire ou pas et que personne n'a
d'informations et ça me paraît pas être
aujourd'hui
complètement à l'ordre du jour dans ces
strictement rien donc je veux rien dire
là-dessus donc vous ne suivez pas
Marie-Noël linman quand elle propose un
changement de cap avec les communistes
elle a le droit de s'exprimer c'est une
parole forte là j'étais plutôt d'accord
avec elle d'ailleurs sur la réaction
qu'elle faisait vis-à-vis des élus qui
quittaient le parti en disant que c'est
l'inverse de la politique l'aventure
individuelle ça n'a aucun sens
personnelle mais elle comprenait quand
même certaines critiques hein
c'est l'inverse de la démarche je dis
voilà c'est une voix aujourd'hui au
Parti socialiste qui est minoritaire et
donc ne peut pas porter la ligne du
parti socialiste c'est clair alors à
propos d'électrochettes on en a parlé
effectivement l'hypothèse de rémuniement
il aura lieu mais on ne sait pas quand
un jour forcément un jour forcément vous
finirez par avoir raison même si c'est
certain évoque même et on lit ça dans
sous certaines plumes mais une
dissolution qui aurait l'avantage pour
François Hollande de se retrouver en
président de cohabitation et d'avoir de
meilleures chances en 2017 je pense que
ceux qui écrivent ça j'ai lu ça comme
vous il devait vraiment être en panne
sèche l'idée pour pouvoir remplir du
papier je dois dire que là pour le coup
ça me paraît quand même assez singulier
comme analyse mais bon il y a des
week-ends
apparemment François Hollande était dans
une posture d'équilibrisme on en a parlé
il y a un instant entre idéalisme et
réaliste incarné par celui qui connaît
une embellie constante dans les sondages
lui au moins c'est Manuel Valls François
Goulin
dans la guerre des gauches c'est le camp
de Manuel Valls qui domine même si
l'affaire léonarda a quelque peu
égratigné sa popularité au sein du parti
il reste le ministre le plus apprécié
des sympathisants socialistes en face
l'aile gauche du PS peine à faire
entendre sa voix celle qui dénonce une
droiteisation idéologique cette gauche
qui gouverne et qui se dit modernise ses
socio-libéraux à la française estimaient
être l'avenir du parti face au vieille
lune et archaïsme socialiste je veux
dire c'est presque une vérité d'évidence
que de dire que ce sont ceux qui
gouvernent qui s'imposent parce que sont
eux quand même qui ont la légitimité
populaire par l'expérience c'est pas la
pratique gouvernementale que
la gauche progresse ce modernise et
répond aux attentes des Français que
cette gauche là se prétende moderne fait
bondir les plus à gauche du PS très
critique envers les récentes actions du
gouvernement et notamment en matière
d'immigration et de sécurité l'affaire
léonarda justement un raviver les
fractures
ceux qui veulent le progrès ceux qui
veulent le socialisme partager les
richesses sauf qu'ils veulent réduire
les inégalités sont toujours modernes
pas les aboyeurs pas les pas les gens
qui vous qui vous prennent le petit la
petite fille à la sortie de l'école par
les gens qui vous font un discours sur
les migrants d'origine européenne non
inséré je les appelle comme ça moi je
dis pas que c'est des gens qui sont pas
insérés ça n'a rien de moderne c'est
très vieux
le conflit n'est pas prêt de s'apaiser
d'autant que le Président de la
République donne des gages aux uns et
aux autres étant une politique
d'équilibriste les positions du ministre
de l'intérieur hystérisent de plus en
plus ses opposants la source de la
division c'est lui hurle les socialistes
de l'ancienne école n'était pas lui qui
voulait tout remettre en cause au sein
du parti jusqu'à son nom
nous a rejoints par une bonsoir vos
questions au ministre chargé des
Relations avec le Parlement c'est la
guerre des modernes contre les anciens
relancés au sein du Parti socialiste
je pense que si on veut faire un effort
de clarification je dirais que
il sait pas les sociaux libéraux qui
dirigent aujourd'hui le Parti socialiste
et que ce sont ceux qui au fond
s'affichent délibérément comme des
sociaux-démocrates avec une ce qui
dirige la France et le participe
vous avez situé le le débat les
interlocuteurs sont forcément des
socialistes le gouvernement ils parlent
français je pense que nous sommes des
sociaux démocrates modernes et que il y
a tout à construire et que effectivement
certains de ces démocratie assumaient
totalement ça veut dire quoi la social
démocratie c'est quelque chose d'assez
clair la sociale démocratie c'est cette
idée que
d'abord
nous sommes dans une économie de marché
soyons clairs même si c'est un peu
basique ce que je vais dire
me semble pas que les gens
peut-être quelques heures mais pas de
cela pense que il faut nationaliser
toutes l'économie et que notre modèle ça
serait plus bas ou la Corée du Nord je
crois pas bon il y a des entreprises
dans un pays et que un gouvernement de
gauche se donne pour mission de dire il
y a la situation des entreprises et on
ne peut pas faire comme si elles
existaient pas ou ne pas se dire
qu'elles sont là pour créer des
richesses d'où ce qui a été fait et en
même temps il y a la situation des
salariés il y a la question des services
publics vous savez l'agnement de la
fiscalité sur les entreprises mais le
pacte
de compétitivité vous savez on peut nous
dire tout ce qu'on veut alors au
détriment des ménages non c'est l'argent
public qui sert à alléger le coût du
travail puisqu'on font
ça mais vous savez mais vous savez ce
qui était intéressant
il y a eu des bas budgétaires il y avait
un contre-projet
l'UMP a élaboré en contre-projet le
président de la commission des finances
de l'Assemblée nationale a dit ben voilà
ce qu'on ferait nous mais c'est
extrêmement intéressant parce que si
certains se posent la question de savoir
quelle est la différence entre la droite
et la gauche alors moi je les renvoie ça
puisque leur réponse est ah ben oui on
va faire des économies alors on va
commencer par geler les salaires des
fonctionnaires par geler les pensions
par remettre en cause 15.000
suppressions de postes de fonctionnaires
tous les ans bon c'est la vraie droite
et ceux qui se posent ces questions là y
compris Marino à Lima je les renvoie ça
non c'est un gouvernement de gauche qui
est au pouvoir dans la cacophonie
actuelle on peut se demander si le
gouvernement n'a pas grillé ces
dernières cartouches pour apparaître
comme un parti de gouvernement crédible
ça ça peut être votre votre appréciation
mais je vais essayer de vous convaincre
et au quotidien quand on est quand on
est des premiers résultats ne sont pas
là mais enfin il y a une logique il y a
une cohérence dans la politique qu'on a
menée qu'on a mené depuis le début et
c'est quand même ça logique ni cette
cohérence
c'est quand même ça qui est essentiel
sur des fondements politiques qui sont
majeurs premièrement est-ce que ce pays
doit retrouver son indépendance ça
souveraineté ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que le politique puisse encore
faire quelque chose et là la situation
qu'on trouve avec un endettement majeur
fait c'est que son chacun la bien vu des
agences de notation qui décidaient donc
il faut se désendetter et il faut
réduire le déficit c'est pas le choix
idéologique c'est un passage obligé pour
le retour à la démocratie c'est quand
même fondamental ça c'est ce que ce
gouvernement a fait ensuite
jusqu'au bout quand même pour le désert
de la France
vous pouvez pas contester et que on a
enfin commencé à réduire les déficits et
bon c'est quand même essentiel ça fait
18 mois que nous sommes là donc c'est ce
que nous avons engagé comme avant ce
gouvernement en même temps a dit nous
allons
mettre la priorité sur ce qui nous Jean
de gauche nous importe l'école enfin
bien sûr on parle pas des trains qui
arrivent à l'heure mais la rentrée
scolaire a quand même été il y a des il
y a des gens il y a des enseignants
quand même sur l'application de la
réforme
auprès des enfants les postes qui ont
été créés qui étaient un choix politique
ils sont là et ça ça me paraît quand
même essentiel comment vous expliquer
alors qui est autant de critiques contre
l'exécutif qu'est-ce qui tourne par rond
c'est un problème de communication pas
seulement non
non on sait jamais la faute des autres
c'est toujours notre faute mais parce
que probablement qu'il y a une
impatience et la fracture est forte
aussi les difficultés sociales elles
sont majeures
en ce moment
ça atteint toujours les critiques mais
ça ne doit rien altérer notre
détermination qu'on croit on croit
ce qu'on fait je dirais on a une
légitimité pour le faire la seule
possible l'élection du peuple et en même
temps et en même temps on le lui
reproche le président de la République à
7 méthodes qui est la sienne et je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure et qu'on lui reproche
effectivement beaucoup du dialogue dans
une société qui est aussi fracturée ça
me paraît au moins au moins aussi
honorable que la brutalité et ce
qu'il y a un entourage du président de
la République dans
l'organisme
le cabinet du Président de la République
c'est strictement rien et dans tous les
cas ce que je vis au quotidien pour être
je dirais assez proche des
non je dirais le problème il est pas de
cette nature le problème il était c'est
que les Français les Français la vie
quotidienne est difficile la vie
quotidienne est difficile ils ont envie
que leur vie quotidienne s'améliore
quand le chômage ça s'améliore enfin ça
continue il y a quand même 5000 chômeurs
de plus je veux dire il voit bien quand
même c'est que les Français ne font plus
confiance à François Hollande et que le
seul les Français
dans ce gouvernement c'est Manuel
regardez les derniers sondages un avis
d'Alice
et je suis très heureux que son action
soit même un meilleur candidat à la
présidentielle que François Hollande moi
je veux pas je veux dire je sais très
bien que la politique politicienne les
sondages si ça n'a strictement aucun
intérêt c'est en 2017 il y a un
président de la République aujourd'hui
en novembre 2013
ce qui est un intérêt aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement d'avoir dans l'équipe des
jeunes des ministres de qualité dans
Manuel Valls qui je crois en plus je
veux le dire parce que je partage cette
conviction avec lui son discours
républicain son attachement aux valeurs
républicaines c'est un rap un rempart
essentiel contre la montée du Front
National et toute l'équipe bénéficie de
ce positionnement parce que c'est aussi
le nôtre et de l'exprime avait talents
y compris
tout à l'heure de la côte d'alerte de la
popularité du chef de l'État et certains
s'interroge d'ores et déjà bien sûr sur
son procès en légitimité que
répondez-vous à cela
la parole est libre les gens peuvent
s'interroger vous savez je regardais bon
moi c'est sondages sont pas bons mais
enfin il y a eu d'autres périodes ou au
lieu d'être à 26 ils étaient à 31
mais là est-ce que la différence entre
légitimité la légitimité c'est les 5
points entre 26 et 31 moi je vous laisse
la responsabilité de cette approche le
Premier ministre est le président de la
République ont quand même été sifflé par
exemple à Marseille au lendemain du
second tour de la primaire PS par des
militants socialistes ça ça vous
interpelle pas ça vous gêne pas mais
franchement vous pouvez comme ça
additionner
tout va bien les événements mais je vous
dis pas que tout va bien mais je veux
dire entre l'écume des choses et le fond
de ce que vivent les Français je pense
qu'il y a une différence et que on peut
on doit entendre ce que sont les
questions de fond que se posent les
Français alors est-ce qu'on
participe pas la même réponse que sur
l'Elysée sur le Parti socialiste
pourquoi sur l'organisation de l'Elysée
parce que
critiqué à gauche les critiques contre
globalement le Parti socialiste a un
problème et puis c'est pas un problème
de personne c'est un problème qui est
assez
redondant quel est le positionnement
d'un parti politique lorsque il soutient
il soutient le gouvernement c'est
extrêmement difficile et se
positionnement et pas facile c'est pas
facile à trouver
le chef de ce parti politique au pouvoir
critiquer son président de la République
à peine deux heures après une
intervention à la télévision je parle là
de l'affaire Léonardo
il a l'air d'aller bien
je vous ai dit ce que je pensais de son
intervention d'accord justement dans
l'affaire léonarda la famille des brani
a déposé un recours pour un éventuel
recours retour elle pourrait revenir ou
penser la famille des Brasil la famille
de Leonardo
c'est l'honneur de ce pays il y a des
lois et s'il y a des recours qui sont
engagés
petite connaissance juridique qui me
paraît quand même que ce recours là qui
ne serait que le nième il est quand même
extrêmement aléatoire et probablement
voué vous voyez l'échec regardez les
arguments mis en avant par cet avocate
de Besançon
dès lors qu'un juge est saisi c'est lui
qui appréciera et c'est bien comme ça
d'accord est-ce que vous redoutez de
nouvelles manifestations de lycéens à la
rentrée après les vacances de la
Toussaint
je vois pas très bien quelle serait
qu'elle serait le fondement
voilà il y a eu une proposition qui a
été faite elle a été suffisamment
critiquée par le Président de la
République et souhaité à la fois
rappeler la règle de droit et le respect
des décisions de justice et avoir un
geste puisqu'il y avait eu un
dysfonctionnement
les lycéens même s'ils sont encouragés
par votre ami un jour Vincent placé
je lui réserverai là sur cette affaire
la même observation que précédemment les
goût du meilleur dans ces interventions
que celle-là
c'est pas la meilleure de ces
interventions c'est clair
le budget de la Sécurité sociale a été
adopté tout à l'heure par l'Assemblée
nationale avec le volet épargne donc en
sursis est-ce que les modifications vont
être apportées j'imagine ici au Sénat
alors la nouvelle lecture au Sénat ça va
être quoi par quel biais par des
amendements du Gouvernement par des
amendement du rapporteur vous avez fait
la question de la réponse d'accord les
amendements du par les amendements du
Gouvernement j'ajoute simplement que le
texte a été voté tout à l'heure à
l'Assemblée nationale par 320 voix
contre 243 et ce qui est important par
rapport à cette majorité que l'on dit
diviser c'est que sur les questions
essentielles la loi de finances
du pays le budget la loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale l'ensemble des
parties membres de la majorité se sont
rassemblés à l'Assemblée nationale
dernière question très rapidement sur le
travail du dimanche et une décision
aujourd'hui de la cour d'appel de Paris
qui autorise Castorama et Leroy Merlin à
rouvrir mais pas Bricorama on est
complètement perdu est-ce qu'il va y
avoir une loi sur le travail du dimanche
qui va simplifier tout ça
il y aura peut-être une loi la décision
n'est pas prise dans tous les cas il y
aura un dispositif juridique nouveau
vous le savez la décision qui a été
prise c'est de confier à Monsieur Bailly
voilà une étude sur ces questions là
avec les problèmes éventuellement
d'ajustement parce que je partage votre
votre appréciation sur le caractère
assez difficilement compréhensible y
compris des décisions
la justice mais il me semble qu'il y a
pas forcément de logique dans les
décisions successives mais peut-être
qu'on a pas tous les éléments dans tous
les cas il faut vous aviez quel est
votre position sur l'addition de la
justice on appelle l'autorisation est
donnée non respectent les décisions de
justice il y a une non il y a une règle
de droit aujourd'hui cette règle droit
va manifestement est assez ambiguë elle
a abouti à des décisions peut-être une
loi si c'est nécessaire mais pourquoi je
dis ça c'est pas pour échapper à la
question c'est que pour entrer dans un
débat plus juridique probablement que
s'il y a des modifications elles peuvent
aussi intervenir simplement par décret
merci c'est pas trop dur de monter au
front pour défendre le gouvernement
auquel vous avez vos appartenez vous
parlez du courage du chef de l'État et
vous en faut j'en suis j'en suis très
heureux j'en suis très heureux et au
contraire voilà au contraire au
contraire je suis très content de venir
défendre la politique du gouvernement ça
me fait merci plaisir et merci et merci
à vous et je reviendrai autant de fois
que merci bonsoir à tous et à très vite